[Musique]
au même moment david arrive dans le
village de menetou-salon un village du
10ème siècle dont l'activité est
entièrement tourné autour de la
viticulture le cadre idéal pour une
tonnellerie artisanale mais c'est arrivé
dans l'atelier de fabien qui n'est autre
que le frère de guillaume je chantais
d'aller d'un jour fabien ça va très bien
comme tu voi che sur le feu là et je
commence à faire une mise en rose l'âge
fini de développer et gérer ça l'art du
tonneau une discipline millénaire
fabien fait partie des compagnons de
france et son savoir faire repose tant
sur la maîtrise que sur l'instinct et
l'expérience et de la géométrie
tout commence par la mise en rose les
deux doigts elles sont dépliés les unes
à côté des autres avant d'être cercle et
sous un feu ardent aucune marge d'erreur
possible
est-ce qu'il ya besoin de télé là où tu
fais ça tout seul tenant surtout parlé
des ça serait plus compliqué en fait ça
ça veut dire les secourir en fer et aux
avec une main et prendre avec l'autre
tout en gardant le même angle si tu as
bien fait ton calcul théoriquement à la
casse et des zones éparses et de la
géométrie et 1
le squale est voilà il a joué qu'à
ajuster mais vraiment parti deuxième
étape le mouillage à l' homo et c'est
pour éviter que le feu à l'intérieur
viennent vous voulez c'est bien une
chose dont on parle et pas de brûler la
barre est d'accord al assad à partir
pour dix minutes de pression et 7
préchauffe va servir à casser la
résistance mécanique du bois dit comme
ça on dirait de la physique des corps
terrestre mais ça sert surtout à courber
la douelle pour donner aux tonneaux sa
forme incurvée et attention
la température doit être constante si je
vais à 130 la nature
bing ça casse hélas déjà au bout de
quelques minutes de travail on est
quasiment à l'horizontale enfin on est
quasiment linéaire
[Musique]
et là maintenant on va serrer
mécaniquement avant d'aller au butinage
saladier
le bourrinage une étape fondamentale ici
se joue non seulement l'avenir de la
barrique mais aussi celui du vin qui l'a
remplira ça va apporter des arômes
différenciant chose peut on va être su
plus tôt sur des notes vives pour
apporter de la tension en vain ou quand
le contenant détermine le contenu plus
on chauffe en exagérant va avoir des
choses poster caféine et c'est presque
de la philosophie ça va donner des notes
vraiment complètement différente ça
dépend du vin et c'est vraiment de
l'amour
d'ailleurs est-ce que tu connais la
professionnels de la vigne dans les
parages où est on peut pas faire mieux à
s'en remettre à une petite vigneronne
très bien super on vous ai dit que même
plus ce salon était un petit monde
cette journée au pays du tonneau finira
donc chez patricia une productrice
locale en compagnie de guillaume
[Musique]
le vin y vivent et le beausset donc et
finalement vous construisez un vin tous
ensemble quoi vous collaborez
aujourd'hui je suis très content d'être
présent pour cette réunion c'est
toujours du partage
mais merci j'ai découvert quelque chose
de formidable
merci à toi donc on va gratter dernière
fois on peut tenter
[Musique]